yeah you know that's what happened to me
i had a panic attack on howard stern's
show
and uh uh he was they were
around in the room there was somebody
who had done i think it was uh
anyway some guy pulled his dick out he
was playing with his dick on the show
and he was there and then he left and i
saw that he touched the door
so when i finished my uh segment with
howard i was about to leave
and i was wearing like short sleeves and
and i said can somebody grab the door i
don't want to touch the door
that guy had his dick all over the door
and they go no just open the door i go
i'm a germaphobe i don't want to touch
the door they go i touched the door they
were having
fun with me and i said no and i went to
grab a tissue to grab the door and they
knocked the
uh the tissue away from me and then i
was trying to pull out my
shirt tail and they were holding me from
that and
i started to have a i've never really
talked openly about it before
and i started to have a panic attack and
i and i was going and
a panic attack feels for those who have
never had one like i'm having a heart
attack i can't breathe
and i couldn't function and i was
getting dizzy and i said howard howard
howard you got to get me out of here i'm
going to end up in the hospital i go to
a
psychiatrist i have something called
obsessive compulsive disorder i'm on
uh medication please you got to help me
now i'm going to pass out i'm going to
pass out i'm going to open the door for
me got to open the door
so he went okay okay and he opened the
door and i went out in the hall and i
was sure that
we were in a commercial when i was
leaving you know he had finished with me
and i was sure we were in a commercial
but i heard as soon as i walked out the
other door
they were still they go whoa whoa what
the was that what happened to howie
and i realized
we were on the air and that went out
nationally and you have to realize for
me
that was the very first time that i had
ever
mentioned publicly besides to besides to
my own
family my maybe closest friends and my
uh therapist and psychiatrist what my
issue was
and i was devastated when i heard it
coming through the speakers
i i went and my first thought was
this is the end
this is the absolute end number one
my family's going to hear this and
anybody they know you know i have three
children
and my wife is in la now it's on the air
that
you know i have mental health issues
that i'm going to be
with number one they're going to be
ridiculed at school your dad's a mental
case he has mental health issues this is
where my
god number two i'm never going to be
able to get a job again any job
you know they take insurance when i say
that i have mental health issues and i'm
medicated and i need to see a
psychiatrist
who's going to want to hire me and
number three i'm just so humiliated and
depressed
this is the end and i'm standing there
and i get in the elevator in manhattan
and i'm going down the
the elevator and i think this is the end
i i don't even know how to face my own
children i'm just going to run into
traffic i don't know what to do
and i got down to the lobby and i'm
looking through the lobby manhattan the
most
teeming city in the world with thousands
of people out on the streets
and and the traffic and i go through the
automatic doors and doors open i'm
standing there on the sidewalk and i'm
just
you know getting up the wherewithal to
take my leak
into traffic and as it
was some guy comes up into my periphery
i couldn't make eye contact i didn't i
didn't want to i was just looking down
and he goes are you howie mandel and i
went yeah
he goes i just heard you on stern and i
could physically feel
my heart drop into my stomach you know
and i went oh my god
you know i'm just gonna run one and i
went two
and and he whispered in my ear i could
feel the air of his
breath on my ear and he went me too
and this is before me too meant what it
means now and i went i didn't know what
it meant
what does that mean me too he goes no i
suffer
too i'm very depressed and i'm very
anxious and i have
it was so thank you for you know
doing that publicly like i didn't do it
on purpose but he goes it made me feel
like i'm not alone
and i said well you just and i turned to
him you just
you just opened up a little door for me
i you know the the one
overwhelming in our darkest moments if
there was
one description that you could give to
anybody in their darkest moments is
is that they feel alone they feel so
like look what's happening to me look at
this dark hole i'm going down look at
what's happening
it's not you're not there is no company
in that there is no joy
in having other people around but now i
have this other person around and he
made me feel good i didn't run into
traffic and i'm here today
but after that this is before email and
before
the internet i started getting every
week i started getting a ton and ton of
a ton tons of uh letters and mail going
thank you
thank you and you had no idea i wasn't
helping them but every time i got these
letters
it helped me i go oh my god it's how
nice is this
to be able to know that you're not alone
it's like the buddy system in swimming
you know
it could be cold it could be choppy but
there's other people there and if you
need help just
reach out your arm they're there and
what uh
what uh a journey from that moment on
the sidewalk in manhattan
to sitting here and talking to you today
is is night and day that's the yin and
the yang and what needs to happen
for absolutely everyone